Hey youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Non Spoilery Star Wars
Episode 7 Review.
Now, most of you might not have seen it yet,
I am going to do a spoilery review later in
the week with Easter Eggs.
There is a new round of the giveaway I'm still
giving away free movie tickets so all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video it's a gift
certificate for the value of two IMAX tickets
which is about 50 bucks let's get going initial
take away totally love this movie I totally
expected to like it going into it there wasn't
anything the completely disappointed me yeah
there were a few things that I felt could
have been better this is very much a JJ Abrams
movie so if you don't like JJ Abrams movies
and you probably have the same complaints
that you have of other JJ Abrams movies I
feel like across the board all the characters
are perfect especially the new characters
there's some of the most interesting characters
to come in the Star Wars universe that I've
ever seen I don't of the original trilogy
or prequel characters under the bus but I
feel like Kylo Ren is the character that Anakin
Skywalker was meant to be during the prequel's
is not your typical villain he has very complex
motivations and I cannot wait to see his character
developed through episode eight and nine just
like the other characters are and that's one
of the best things about the characters is
that there's no clear good or evil like everyone
is very very complex a lot of you guys that
have been tweeting at me of the movie about
Poe Dameron saving he's your favorite new
character you can't wait to hear more about
them I was a of all the characters he's the
closest to being a lawful good in terms of
alignment you're very pulpy very Flash Gordon
type of character always thinks of his friends
first never buckles under pressure or happy
to throw himself in a danger to help someone
out Finis hilarious gets all the best funny
moments John boy get absolutely crushed it
as heartbreaking as some of the twists are
you feel that instant connection between him
and the other main characters that you cannot
wait to see them do more stuff together if
you have seen the movie then it's probably
no surprise that Daisy Ridley is my favorite
character coming out this raise character
because this is supposed to be a non-spoil
review all say is that she completely succeeds
in turning a lot of the tropes of the Star
Wars universe on their head she is the hero
that you're looking for and in being a hero
she doesn't undercut any the other characters
either like no one character gets development
at the expense of another character nobody
gets thrown under the bus despite fish aching
you might hear in the back row the real task
of this movie was to reignite the Star Wars
universe to create something that's completely
independent from the other Star Wars movies
while at the same time honoring them with
a certain amount of continuity now it doesn't
completely throw the prequel stuff away but
mostly invokes things from the original trilogy
so when you're looking for Easter eggs mostly
think about original trilogy stuff but Abrams
completely succeeded in the task I thought
I feel one of the weaknesses of the movie
one of the very few weaknesses is that there
are a couple leaps in logic that the movie
asked you to make but I feel like the only
reason that happens is because they cut a
lot of scenes all of Abrams films have this
real sense of kinetic energy that the Star
Wars movie definitely has but in order to
do that you have to lose a lot of connective
tissue that you find in films movable a bit
slower little more deliberately so one of
the big strengths of the movie also leads
to one of its weaknesses Sears in the movie
is a little under 2 1/2 hours if it were like
a three hour movie I think if you like there's
less connective tissue that's missing just
in terms of logic and drop plot points but
usually you can forgive that especially if
you're seeing it for the first time your maybe
that's the fifth time using the movie you
might start pointing out some of the flaws
hold the bore and I think it will be easier
to compare the quality of this film two episode
eight when that's released is because this
is so different from the other Star Wars movies
just in terms of visual style what's going
on in the galaxy that is like comparing apples
to oranges to try and compare this to the
prequel's or the original trilogy but I will
say that Empire still my favorite Star Wars
movie this is my second favorite Star Wars
movie now what about BB8 we had to talk about
him a little bit though he is to fill some
very large trademarks for R2-D2 and actually
just found out I laugh so hard Bill Hader
in Ben Schwartz who was Jean Rafio from Parks
and rec did the voice for BB8 I mean I mean
they they modify their voices quite a bit
Abrams said that when they were creating the
droid BB8 they wanted a droid companion that
made sounds that children could mimic that
you know you could see little kids walking
around making the sounds so when you see BB8
rolling around just picture Jean Rafio and
Bill Hader just making funny noises into like
a little microphone even though you do connect
with the human performance is the most there
is a lot of motion capture characters like
Maz Kanata or supreme leader snoke I feel
like Lupita was awesome Andy Serkis' performances
always goes without saying he is one of the
most amazing motion capture artist in the
world snoke is a good example of a character
we can't really talk about without getting
to spoilers i'll talk about him more during
my Easter Egg video but there's going to be
a lot to unpack from this movie because it
in no way answers every single question that
you have like it all of you actually here's
my question for you guys write in the comments
what was your biggest question coming out
of the movie or maybe even going into the
movie did that change going in and coming
out like were there big questions that you
had the movie didn't answer is the attention
of Lucasfilm to like slowly answer some of
these questions through the trilogy in the
spinoff films but a lot of the expanded material
to this like the novel pick up a lot of slack
but some people might consider that lazy storytelling
but I just feel like it's fun for us to try
and figure those things out like sometimes
it's worse when everything gets explained
so take that as a challenge tumbler start
answering as many questions as possible I
don't have a talk a lot about the original
trilogy characters other there's only so much
that we can talk about them you without getting
to spoilers but on in layout like we've seen
them in the trailer so I'll talk about them
there is some very poignant cry were the moments
that they have in the film without necessarily
explaining what the dynamic is between them
there is so much energy between them when
they're on screen together it's so amazing
but in the realist of terms one of the other
big jobs this movie was to pass the torch
to the new characters it didn't amazing job
of doing that so as excited as you are to
have seen this movie if you haven't seen it
yet when you're walking out of it you will
probably be even more excited to see what
happens in episode eight now here's the next
thing you need to get really excited about
to like if there's this there's certain JJ
Abrams tropes that you're not really happy
about like some of that the film techniques
that he uses he's amazing at finding talent
writing characters but you know there's always
like you know minor techniques like like lens
flare he was gets criticized for further even
like a few of the CG scenes the kind of take
yet the action just because there like that
just to overblown a remember Rian Johnson
is directing and writing episode eight so
JJ Abrams will only loosely be involved so
if some of your bigger complaints are JJ Abrams
specific complaints than those of already
been answered so there's no need to worry
but are probably going to be doing next is
a spoiler he review with Easter eggs looks
like a spoiler Easter egg video to more like
the top 10 WTF format that I normally do but
I'll also do videos for each of the big characters,
we can talk about them all day I know I said
Rey's characters my favorite Kylo Ren also
like really close second with Poe Dameron
think they're all just so amazing so if you
haven't already let me know in the comments
who is your favorite character coming out
of this film and have you seen it more than
once already and it's only been out for a
couple days but I'm always curious to see
if like anyway just stays in the theater and
watch as multiple viewings just and things
there was this really huge comment that Lucas
may when he was making the prequel's were
he's like they rhyme your they rhyme with
the original trilogy that's a way of saying
that there are a lot of familiar story beats
familiar characters familiar things you know
like visually and somatically they rhyme with
the original trilogy so this film also rhymes
a lot with the original trilogy but you could
also say that it is certain point it almost
rhymes a little too much but I don't I don't
think that that hurts the film at all I think
that's part of the intention is just meant
to be the connective tissue between the other
films that have come before in this new universe
that they're spinning out so I'm expecting
the newer films to go into much more uncharted
territory just in terms of places we visited
the way environments looked the types of ships
that we see I mean it's always going to be
familiar because it Star Wars but it's a big
galaxy and we have not seen all of it not
even close yet knowing I said empires my favorite
Star Wars movies still I'm curious to see
if episode eight winds up being the Empire
of the new trilogy I've I feel like Rian Johnson
is sweating just feeling like he is going
to be compared Empire so much so while you
wait for my spoilery Star Wars Easter egg
video to post you can click here for all my
other episode 7 videos I made a giant playlist
and you can click here to learn all about
the 12 days of Deadpool thank you so much
for watching, everybody let's high five and
I'll see you in line for Star Wars again in
a couple days!